hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the joy of creation
now this is the story mode demo which
means that there's a full game of this
coming out soon but the previous
incarnations of this game were kind of
just technical demos to show you what
these horrifying animatronic and ooh but
this one takes place in a lovely living
room what could go wrong I say so
confidently to myself as I wait to be
torn apart and stuffed inside a doe am i
oh no hello
oh oh whoa whoa oh why am i going
towards that door hello oh okay
how do I get though there we go good god
ah okay this isn't what I thought it was
gonna be it's got a little bit different
okay alright so poor
knew that I didn't do it whatever then
okay excuse my bitchiest nature there
I'm not ready for this Ivan [ __ ] was it
the [ __ ] god damn it hey how's it
going okay
alright now I'm starting to get it okay
so I remember I remember the first joke
region game that I ever did was a lot
like this oh hi
I see you down there I see you I got you
okay what do I do about that is there
Freddie where's that Bonnie who is that
who are you
oh god yeah okay well that's not good
okay so chicas on the monitor okay so if
there's a Freddy oh yeah that stop doing
that
who's turning out the lights okay so
there's a Freddy poster on this side I'm
assuming that assuming that that's ready
chicas over there pretties over there oh
that's a Barney poster on the right so
right I did
is there an option but that must have
been
hi there we go hi who's there
is there someone someone there I spy at
the back what the [ __ ] was that a door
opening I think it was like a chief hey
he's that foxy that better not be foxy
back there
I'll give him a watt for what's on my
mind ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
I shouldn't answer this door should I
hello
what oh holy [ __ ] [ __ ] high five to
fifty [ __ ] [ __ ] what does that mean
game over yes no no no that means what
do you want from me oh my god no no yes
yes no I do bro
I'm assuming that was like a continued
thing just written a little weirdly
alright so now that I got my bearings
maybe I can last longer than Oh a little
under three minutes okay so all right so
Freddy is over there but Bonnie's over
there Foxy's coming at you from behind
and chicas over there so
what we gotta do is a whole lot of I
don't [ __ ] know we got a hopefully
survive long enough to be able to tell
our families what the hell happened to
us hello they're gonna be oh hi I see
you down there oh you're far away aren't
you well that's okay I'd rather you I
was yeah shut the [ __ ] up man okay is it
bad that the lights say off what I'm I'm
kind of tempting [ __ ] foxy you're not
welcome here you have no friends here
you have lots of friends outside of here
and they're all trying to get here but
you're just a little early to the party
why don't you go home go home foxy okay
so Bonnie or at least withered Bo ah how
are you doing I shouldn't stare and you
should I but I just can't help it you're
so goddamned off I was back I was right
there okay know what I'm gonna tempt
fate here
they want to see if chica comes crawling
out as TV like the goddamn ring bumpy
[ __ ] [ __ ] but I'm just going to
waste this attempt on unwanted death
nothing over there nothing over there
okay that's [ __ ] what was that what
was that what was it
and here's something whoa here's nothing
hey see my ears
oh I'm beginning to think that this is a
bad idea I'm beginning to think that I
maybe shouldn't have done this
oh why am i committing to this ah we can
turn on the light ahead Egon there mama
oh [ __ ] I'm dead I'm dead unless I'm not
which is cool too ha ha oh my fine weed
I survived two seconds shorter than the
last time god damn it
alright let's try that again this time
with a lot less stupid I don't even know
if that was chica that got me I closed
my eyes like the little [ __ ] baby that
I am should I keep an autumn like the
question raised in my mind god damn it
hang on holy [ __ ] - hold on hold hold
hold your [ __ ] god damn it so anyway
I don't know if I finish my thought
before because I was screaming like an
idiot why is that the thing that it is
that but this is a lot like the very
first joy of creation game that I played
if this is this is obviously not free
Rome it's kind of blending five nights
at Freddy's 4 with some other thing but
this is what the first one was about
who's about spinning around in a room
and trying to make sure that no one
murders you but I'm still trying to
wonder wait is offensive
oh no the vents nothing okay I'm still
trying to wonder why am I in this room
in the first place how did I get here
why am i watching this on the TV because
in five nights at freddys at least I was
just looking at you in five nights at
freddys million what the [ __ ] was that
you gotta warn me first [ __ ] off with
you
oh it's quiet oh it's quiet anyway ah
[ __ ]
before I question the logic of this game
any further oh [ __ ] off with you the
thunders really picking up it's one
pitch woo five nights at freddys you
were a security guard in a security post
if this is supposed to be story mode I
don't know what the story is
oh why what does that do why did I do
that
okay Oh get it I don't get it so if you
clip forward you kind of huh hi hi okay
are is that how you do it to do the
quick turnaround on that one ah that
might be it okay so let's check over on
good ol pawn barn are you doing Bonzo
you better not be scared well who's
behind you who the [ __ ] is behind you
who's behind you who the [ __ ] is that
why that's not explain that one more who
the [ __ ] is behind him who the [ __ ] was
behind him there were more eyes Oh get
broth [ __ ] bakit the [ __ ] back
get [ __ ] buff walk so who was behind
it all
god damn and stop that who who's behind
him or is is that just a reflection is
that a very inconvenient reflection it
could be but it also could be something
else it's kind of I don't I don't want
to make any bold claims here but it kind
of seems like it might be it's very
narrow that's one thing to note about is
very narrow eyes which kind of reminds
me of the puppet I haven't seen the
puppet at all in this type of game so
it's either the puppet or a very oh god
what's happening
where'd he go he's looking at me no he's
not looking at me he would add ready
[Music]
over three minutes
ah Jesus is hard either there's
something that I'm missing which is
totally understandable considering that
I've never played this game before but
holy [ __ ] I don't know what's going on
I'm gonna give it one more try if you go
towards the door when they're right
outside of it you going to die it's
going to grab your [ __ ] maybe it's just
like total time spent no it's still
there it's still there what is that it's
not just a reflection off of Bonnie
that's something
then that is a hundred percent something
and if I'm not mistaken if you look down
towards the bottom like that piece of
paper flashing I see the shadow of
something spindly like a leg and I may
just be I may just be fooling myself
there but I calls it like I seize it
that's something excuse my spit okay
he's back oh I heard that I heard that
flippity floppity get the floppity okay
can't do anything with the thermostat if
I may why what killed me why oh look
proof it's gone the eyes are gone so
there was something over there there was
definitely something over there there
was a hundred percent something over
there I'll go back right now you guys
can see the eyes are literally there
there now they weren't there before
they're there now that is something what
is that seriously what is that in the
darkness there's been a rogue element
here that's been killing me but I don't
know what the [ __ ] that is
if I like go back and forth between this
isn't gonna progressed it more oh [ __ ]
well that ain't good I'm gonna die
walking what did what did burn what is
that uh that is one one one oh geez okay
I know that doesn't close the goddamn
game okay there's a lot of mysteries in
here and I don't know how to solve them
I'm addict I'm at loss I am and I have
no idea so I'm gonna leave this up to
you guys I'll put a link in the
description below you guys play this for
yourself let me know what you think and
let me know if you find any other
secrets in this because it seems like
there's a lot of them so I'm gonna give
my heart a little bit of a rest here
because my god it would not stop killing
me but either way let me know what you
thought of it down in the comments below
and thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
Oh God Oh